Hallo, merhaba.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Bilal Altan, ich bin hier auf dieser Station,
die Insta-Wende Arzt tätig und ich werde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch
durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, bevor wir über Ihr aktuell besprächsendes Gesprächs
sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Bitte.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Peter Müller.
Könnte Sie bitte vorne und nach Hause buchen zuabieren?
Peter, Peter ist P-E-T-E-R.
Müller, M-U, L-L-E-R.
Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1943.
1963, Entschuldigung.
1. Mai 1963.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin ungefähr 1.83 groß und wiege ungefähr 90 Kilo.
90 Kilo, danke schön.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Bauarbeiter.
Darf ich Ihre Familienstand freien?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Müller, was für Sie zu uns, wie kann ich Ihnen erzählen?
Wie Sie bestimmt schon wissen, bin ich zu Hause fast bewusstlos geworden.
Ich bin umgekippt.
Und Tattif, bitte?
Wann sind Sie gewusstlos gewesen?
Geworfen.
Ich bin gestern Abend gekommen.
Und gestern, bevor ich gekommen bin, habe ich Schmerzen auf der Brust gehabt.
Und dann bin ich bewusstlos geworden.
Gestern Abend, umgekommen, 1-mal, oder?
Sind Sie 2-mal gewusstlos geworden?
1-mal.
Gestern Abend.
Gestern Abend sind Sie gewusstlos geworden?
Ein Moment.
Bitte entweder auf die Terrasse oder auf die Lege.
Bestört.
Ich habe gestern auf dem Bau gearbeitet.
Und dann habe ich Schmerzen auf der Brust gekriegt.
Und dann bin ich umgekippt.
Okay.
Haben Sie so einige Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Eigentlich nicht.
Manchmal, manchmal.
Aber immer nur ganz kurz, ein bisschen.
Aber nicht bewusstlos geworden, das ist das 1. Mal.
Nur früher hatte Sie Brutschmerzen?
Ja, so wie so ein Stechen.
Ganz kurz.
Aber diesmal hat es länger angehalten.
Also diesmal hat es eine halbe Stunde angehalten.
Normalerweise ganz kurz immer.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein?
Also es tut mir halt auch der Brusttuz weh.
Das ist so wie so ein Stechen.
Ja, Frau Herr Müller.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo in den Aufs?
Eigentlich nicht.
Das ist hier so gestern.
Als ich die Schmerzen hatte,
habe ich auch ein bisschen im Rücken gehabt.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass die Schmerzen eine halbe Stunde gedauert haben.
Die Schmerzen oder der Schmerz haben?
Die Schmerzen, ja,
ungefähr eine halbe Stunde gedauert haben.
Genau.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter
oder manchmal gehen wieder?
Nein, ich habe immer wieder nur ganz kurz.
Gestern hat es 30 Minuten.
Jetzt geht es mir wieder gut.
Ich habe jetzt keine Schmerzen mehr.
Herr Müller, ich möchte wissen,
seit wann hatten diese Schmerzen?
Wann haben die Schmerzen überhaupt begonnen?
Kann ich gar nicht genau sagen,
aber ich habe das bestimmt schon ein Jahr lang.
Aber ich habe das jetzt vielleicht insgesamt
3-4 Mal gehabt und jetzt hat es 30 Minuten gedauert.
In einem Jahr.
Okay.
Ich habe das jetzt vielleicht insgesamt
3-4 Mal gehabt.
Und jetzt hat es 30 Minuten gedauert.
Okay, verstanden.
Sind die Schmerzen immer stechend
oder manchmal bruchend,
wie die Brust eng ist?
Gestern war es nicht nur ein Stechen,
sondern gestern war es auch eng auf der Brust.
Okay.
Herr Müller, könnten Sie bitte
die Schmerzen auf eine der Schmerzsehalle bewerten,
wo auch die Schmerzen sind?
Die Schmerzen sind sehr leichter.
Gestern war es vielleicht bei 8.
Haben Sie eine Auslöserbemeldung,
die Schmerzen verursacht?
Ja, ich habe das gestern.
Ich habe das gestern.
Ich habe die Schmerzen verursacht.
Meintlich nicht.
Okay.
Ich kann die wohnen.
Ja.
Vielleicht ein bisschen so menschliches.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Herr Müller?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ich habe das.
Zum Beispiel.
Ist ihr noch schwindelig?
Ist Ihnen noch schwindelig?
Oder ist im Öbel
erbrechen?
Nein.
Jetzt habe ich gar keine Beschwerden mehr.
Gestern habe ich auch nur Beschwerden auf der Brust gehabt.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen bei Belastung vermehrt
vermehrt sind?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Haben Sie zum Beispiel beim Laufen
vermehrt sich die Schmerzen?
Oder in Ruhe
und bei Belastung sind gleich.
Ach so.
Haben Sie vermehrt Beschwerden bei Belastung
vermehrt auf der Arbeit zum Beispiel?
Ja.
Okay, wenn ich arbeite,
meinen Sie?
Oder wenn ich nichts mache, wenn ich in Ruhe?
Ja, also,
wenn ich auf der Arbeit
ist, ist es mehr aufgetreten.
Zum Beispiel können Sie einfach
Treppen steigen
ohne Schmerzen.
Dann habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Herr Müller, Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie keine
Öbelkeit erbrechen haben.
Und
fühlen Sie sich fieberisch?
Haben Sie Husten?
Herzrasen?
Herzstolpern?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, Herzstolpern habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Husten habe ich auch nicht.
Was haben Sie noch gesagt?
Herzrasen?
Nein, Herzrasen habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay, Herr Müller.
Leiden Sie an eine chronische Erkrankung?
Eigentlich habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Ich nehme auch keine Medikamente ein.
Also, meinen Sie
Bluthochdruck und so was?
Ja, ich meine Bluthochdruck,
oder Zuckerkrankheit.
Oder erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Blutfettwerte weiß ich nicht.
Das habe ich nicht kontrollieren lassen, keine Ahnung.
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Eigentlich bin ich gesund.
Und Blutdruck mäß ich auch nicht regelmäßig.
Haben Sie auch nicht
gegen diese Schmerzen
irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Wegen den Beschwerden jetzt?
Ich habe das ja nur ganz kurz gehabt.
Jetzt hat es so lange gedauert
und dann haben wir den Notarzt gerufen.
Und der Notarzt hat mir etwas gegeben.
Das heißt, haben Sie keine Medikamente?
Nein, musste ich nicht.
Gestern war das so schlimm,
weil ich umgefallen bin.
Da hat meine Frau den Notarzt gerufen.
Wissen Sie,
war der Notarzt Ihnen gegeben?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Hat das geholfen?
Ja, es hat geholfen.
Es ist besser geworden, die Schmerzen.
Und jetzt geht es mir wieder ganz gut.
Jetzt geht es mir, jetzt ist alles weg.
Erinnern Sie sich
genau kurz vor
Ohnmacht?
Ja, ich erinnere mich, ich hatte Schmerzen.
Sie meinen, ob ich mich an alles erinnere,
bevor ich ohnmächtig geworden bin?
Ja, ich weiß genau, was passiert ist.
Okay, okay, Herr Müller.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Müller?
Ja, ich hatte schon mal einen Leistenbruch,
was operiert worden ist, aber das ist schon 20 Jahre.
Auf welcher Seite?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Wie leistet diese Leistenbruch?
Behandelt oder operiert?
Ich meine, mit offenen
Leistenbruch,
die haben wir schon einmal,
mit offenen
Operationen oder mit Schlüsselnach-Operationen.
Sie meinen, ob das endoskopisch
echt gemacht worden ist?
Oder ob das meine offene Operation war?
Das ist offene operiert worden vor 20 Jahren?
Und jetzt haben Sie keine Beschwerden?
Nein.
Ja, Herr Müller,
gibt es bei Ihrer Familie
eine bekannte,
eine bekannte chronische Erkrankung?
In meiner Familie.
Meine Mutter ist gesund,
mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt,
mein Bruder hat Stens in seinem Herzen
und meine Schwester ist gesund.
Und meine Schwester ist gesund.
Haben Sie zwei Geschwister?
Ja.
Und lebt Ihr Vater noch?
Ja, mein Vater lebt noch.
Aber er hat
einen Herzinfarkt gelitten.
Herzinfarkt gelitten, muss man nicht sagen.
Er hatte einen Herzinfarkt, ja, er hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Ja, Mutter ist gesund.
Ja.
Danke schön.
Herr Müller, ich möchte jetzt
über Ihre generelle Situation etwas fragen.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie keine Fieber haben.
Und ich möchte wissen jetzt,
ob Sie
gut schlafen können.
Ja, ich kann eigentlich gut schlafen.
Können Sie einfach
im Bett fachlegen?
Ja, ich kann nicht.
Ja, zum Beispiel,
können Sie nur mit einem
mit einem Kissen schlafen?
Oder brauchen Sie manchmal
zweite Kissen?
Nein, ich kann mit einem Kissen schlafen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit?
Ja.
Ist eigentlich ganz gut, ich habe da keine Probleme mit.
Haben Sie in den letzten Zeiten
ab- oder zugenommen?
Eigentlich nicht, so wie immer.
Haben Sie Probleme
beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, funktioniert gut.
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja,
und
über Medikamente möchte ich wiederholen.
Sie habe schon gesagt,
dass Sie keine Medikamente
einnehmen.
Gibt es?
Ja.
Ist das richtig?
Was ist richtig?
Ja, ich nehme keine Medikamente an.
Das ist genau richtig, was Sie gesagt haben.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich wollte mich nur standardmäßig fragen.
Herr Müller, leiden Sie unter Stress
bei der Arbeit oder
im Alltag?
Gibt es etwas, was Sie seelisch belastet?
Verstehe.
Eigentlich nicht.
Das geht mir gut.
Herr Müller,
jetzt über Ihre Gewohnheiten
fragen.
Ich möchte über Ihre Gewohnheiten
etwas fragen.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe auch noch nie geraucht.
Ich habe nie geraucht.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Ich mag kein Alkohol, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Okay.
Und nächste Frage ist eine Urtienfrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein.
Herr Müller,
ich habe nicht so gut vertragen.
Was?
Nickel.
Nickel ist ein Element, oder?
Metall.
Nickel.
Nickel ist ein Element, oder?
Metall.
Nickel.
Wie reagieren Sie sich auf Nickel?
Nicht Sie sich, sondern wie reagieren Sie auf Nickel?
Wie reagieren Sie auf Nickel?
Das ist ja meistens in Metall, zum Beispiel.
Metall legierungen.
Metall legierungen, genau.
Ich habe dann Ausschlag an den Stellen.
Zum Beispiel am Metall.
Metall ist mit Nickel.
Dann habe ich lokal, habe ich an der Stelle, habe ich eine Rötung.
Rötung.
Herr Müller, sind Sie vollständig geimpft
gegen Corona
oder gegen Kindheiterkrankungen?
Gegen Kindheitserkrankungen.
Ich habe nicht so viel mitgegeben.
Ich bin nicht geimpft.
Gegen Corona bin ich dreimal geimpft, wenn das ausreicht.
War man sie in der letzten Zeit in dem Ausland?
Nein.
Letztes Jahr waren wir im Urlaub.
Was meinen Sie letztes Jahr?
Letztes Jahr, wo waren Sie?
Vor einem Jahr waren wir in Griechenland im Urlaub.
Okay.
Herr Müller, ich habe etwas vergessen, dass ich fragen wollte.
Waren Sie im Krankenhaus wegen irgendwelcher Erkrankungen oder ich möchte wissen, ob
bei Ihnen zum Beispiel eine Spiegelung durchgeführt werden?
Woran ist?
Ob bei Ihnen eine Spiegelung durchgeführt worden ist?
Mein Spiegelung?
Darmspiegelung?
Was meinst du?
Meine Spiegelung.
Ja, alles.
Nein, beides nicht.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Müller, von meiner Seite habe ich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, ich möchte natürlich nur wissen, was ich habe und wann ich nach Hause gehen kann.
Ja.
Herr Müller, es wäre besser, wenn Sie jetzt hier bei uns bleiben und ich kann nicht
sofort über Ihre Diagnose etwas zu sagen.
Und möchte ich zuerst Sie ausführlich körperlich untersuchen und dann von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich möchte ein EKG schreiben und danach brauchen wir ein paar diagnostische Maßnahmen wie Ultraschall
oder Röntgen vom Rust und dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose und Therapiemöglichkeit besprechen.
Und wann kann ich nach Hause gehen?
Nach sobald wir Ihre Ergebnisse erhalten, können wir dann ausführlich besprechen und zusammen entscheiden.
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt wäre es besser, wenn Sie bei uns bleiben.
Okay.
Okay, fertig?
Ja.
Wenn meine Kollegen Fragen haben, können Sie auch Fragen.
Also im Chat sehe ich keine Fragen.
Ich hatte ein paar Fragen, Herr Müller.
Guten Abend.
Gestern Abend erinnern Sie sich, wie lange hat Ihre Bewusstlosheit gedauert?
Ihre Bewusstlosheit gibt es nicht Ihre Bewusstlosheit.
Wie lange waren Sie bewusstlos oder hat Ihre Bewusstlosigkeit angedauert?
Okay.
Ich persönlich kann es Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich kann Ihnen nur sagen, was meine Frau gesagt hat und meine Frau hat gesagt, dass hat ungefähr 2 Minuten gedauert.
2 Minuten.
Okay.
Erinnern Sie sich, dass die Nordarzt hat Ihnen eine Spray gegeben?
Bitte was?
Sie Spray.
Noch mal.
Wie bewohnen Sie bitte noch mal?
Erinnern Sie sich, dass die Nordarzt eine Unterzunge Spray angewandelt hat?
Okay. Also Sie wollen mich fragen, ob der Nordarzt mir ein Medikament unter meine Zunge verabreicht hat?
Ja.
Erinnern Sie sich, Sie müssen sagen, erinnern Sie sich, ob der Nordarzt Ihnen vielleicht ein Medikament unter die Zunge verabreicht hat?
Nein, hat er nicht.
Okay.
Hat Sie auch gestern Abend Schweißausbruch gehabt?
Hat Sie nicht. Hatten Sie gestern Abend auch Schweißausbruch gehabt?
Oder hatten Sie oder haben Sie gestern Abend Schweißausbruch gehabt?
Ganz ehrlich gesagt, nein, eigentlich nicht.
Gab es damals Todesangst auch?
Was meinen Sie mit damals?
Ja, ich meine gestern Abend.
Ob ich gestern Abend Angst hatte auch? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich kann mich nur an den Schmerz erinnern. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich Angst hatte.
Und es ging alles ganz schnell.
Ich hatte halt halbe Stunde diese Beschwerden und dann bin ich umgekippt und dann war ich schon im Rettungswagen.
Und dann waren die Beschwerden auch schon wieder vorbei, nachdem ich das Medikament bekommen habe.
Angst kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Das fing sehr schnell.
Ja, ist Ihnen eine dicke Beine auch gefallen?
Dicke Beine? Nein, nein.
Okay. Ich möchte auch wissen, ob Sie gestern eine falsche Bewegung gemacht oder etwas schwer aufgehoben haben.
Okay.
Also Sie arbeiten als Bauarbeiter?
Ja, ich verstehe, was Sie meinen.
Ich habe genau das gemacht wie immer.
Also es ist nicht so, dass ich gestern zum Beispiel etwas schwereres gehoben habe als sonst.
Und gestern habe ich auch insgesamt noch nichts Schwereres gehoben.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Wollen Sie noch fragen?
Herr Müller, ich habe eine Frage.
Aktuell, nach dem Fall, hatten Sie Kraftlosigkeit oder Tröpel, Kröpeln oder Taubaitskäfels, so etwas?
Ja, meine Nacht, nachdem ich umgefallen bin, ob ich danach diese Kraftlosigkeit, Kröpeln oder Empfindungsstörung hatte.
Oder Sprachstörung oder Sechstörung.
Ja, verstehe. Nein, hatte ich nicht.
Im Chat steht noch, ob gestern der Notar hat sein EKG geschrieben hat.
Ja, der Notar hat gestern ein EKG geschrieben.
Aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, er hat gesagt, das EKG war unauffällig.
Er meinte, das EKG sieht gut aus.
Er hat gestern ein EKG geschrieben, der Notar.
Während Sie unmächtig waren, haben Sie gehört, was die Leute, die umgebung Ihnen sind, gesagt hat?
Während ich bewusstlos geworden bin, ob ich gehört habe, was die Menschen in meiner Umgebung gesprochen haben oder gesagt haben.
Ich weiß nicht. Eigentlich würde ich sagen, ja.
Danke schön.
Noch Fragen?
Wir können mit...
Wir können weiter machen, genau.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Frau Obererstin, ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich.
Ja, gerne.
Herr Peter Müller, der 60-jährige Patient, der Bauarbeiter von Beruf,
hat sich bei uns wegen Brustschmerzen und gestern Abend aufgetretene Unmacht vorgestellt.
Die Beschwerden haben ungefähr vor einem Jahr aufgetreten
und drei, vier Mal Brustschmerzen.
Die Beschwerden haben seit einem Jahr begonnen und im letzten Jahr insgesamt drei bis vier Mal aufgetreten.
Noch einmal, bitte.
Die Beschwerden haben vor einem Jahr angefangen und haben insgesamt drei bis vier Mal in einem Jahr aufgetreten.
Die Beschwerden haben seit einem Jahr angefangen.
Vor einem Jahr angefangen, ja, ist egal.
Vor einem Jahr angefangen und drei bis vier Mal aufgetreten.
Der Patient gab an, dass die Schmerzen in den Rücken ausstrahlen
und die Schmerzen stechen sind.
Manchmal fühlt er sich wie ein Engigefühl im Brust.
Normalerweise hat er gesagt, es ist immer wie stechend gewesen und kurz anhaltend.
Gestern Abend das erste Mal auch Beklemmung und lange angehalten, 30 Minuten.
Sonst hält das immer nur ganz kurz an, hat er gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er hat diese Beschwerden in Form von Brust, also in Form von Stechen.
Gestern Abend hatte er das Gefühl, dass es Beklemmung war, zusätzlich zum Stechen.
Gestern Abend hat es das erste Mal auch lange angehalten.
Noch einmal, wiederholen Sie das.
Der Patient erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen immer stechen sind.
Gestern Abend ein Bruch.
Gestern Abend hatte er auch ein Engigefühl.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde bei 8 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Der Patient gab an, dass seine Frau einen Notarzt gerufen hat.
Der Notarzt hat den Patienten ein Medikament gegeben und verabreicht.
Der Patient hat sich nicht an den Namen des Medikamentes erinnert.
Laut seiner Frau sei er erst 2 Minuten umächtig gewesen.
Die Fragen nach Husten, Übelkeit, Erbrechen und Gewichtverlust wurden vermeint.
An vor Erkrankungen liegt eine Inguinall-Operation vor 20 Jahren.
Sie können beides sagen.
Bei der Familie des Patienten gibt es bei der Vater ein Herzinfarkt.
Seine Bruder hatte einen Stand.
Der Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Der Patient hatte keine Medikamente.
Der Patient hatte keinen Stress.
Der Patient hatte nie geraucht und hatte ein Alkohol und trockenen Konsum.
Der Patient hatte eine Nickelallergie.
Der Patient war geimpft 3-mal gegen Corona.
Er ist geimpft gegen Kindererkrankungen.
Ich habe nach alarmistischen Angaben eine Verdacht auf den Verlust.
Ich habe den Verdacht auf den Verlust.
Er hat keine Ödem.
Er hat keine Rheizusin.